hey steve
[Music]
how long have you been juggling i've
been juggling for about 15 years or so
my elementary school had a circus
program after school and so that taught
me the basics i was going into high
school i was like juggling it's kind of
lame part way through high school as
when like youtube was really starting to
take off and like a juggling community
online kind of started to pop up and so
then okay and then i started you know it
just spread the knowledge of what's
possible with juggling and so i i
honestly i thought i was one of the best
troubles in the world when i was in
eighth grade because i could juggle
three torches or whatever but i had no
idea you could even do five i didn't
stop after that that's when i started
training like four hours every day
started competing in world championships
and i did that through through high
school and college these like little
blue bags yeah i'm gonna start with two
so if i was to try three okay i haven't
juggled any probably like three years
wait can you do a four
oh wait how many is that
you kidding me right now nick are you
seeing this
[Music]
[ __ ] one two three four yep nothing
crosstalk nothing
so four this is a standard pattern so it
can be async like this or synchronous
but then there's also ways to cross it
you can throw like but you have to throw
one higher than the other
that's a crossing pattern but standard
standard is just this and then five goes
back to crossing and then seven
uh goes back to crossing
[Music]
there you go
[Music]
what i'd really like to know is what
channels you guys are into what's your
most obvious channel that you're
subscribed to what's the most unlikely
channel that you're subscribed to and
what's the most underrated channel that
you're subscribed to i'm gonna start
most obvious
node i'm obviously subscribed to the
slow-mo guys
west fest tv
snoop dogg's channel
the peat box is pretty cool he's a
real-time musician he like beat boxes
and has one of those like mix pads it's
james townsend and son they sell like
historic reenactment stuff the channel's
mostly cooking from the 18th century
most underrated this is tough moon fleet
41 otherwise known as delboy's garage
he's a motorcycle mechanic out of
england there's obviously gender runner
he actually does a lot of the music you
will hear in these vlogs with all the
new channels out there sometimes you
miss them and i don't want to do that so
that
i can watch it
[Music]
what was that
right dude that was cool
it's called the machine
i'm the machine
[Music]
that's really cool though so you're
doing like
[Music]
[Music]
how do you juggle student loans credit
card debt rising rent i'm working on
that you struggle you too yeah like
what's going through your brain when
you're actually doing this juggling are
you just watching on where the clubs are
going in the air and your arms are just
moving super second nature to me at this
point but everything i showed you i can
do almost with my eyes closed you know
with your eyes closed
[Laughter]
you ready to rock these effects friend i
heard you wanted to do pre-pro on uh
gizmo so i'm trying to set it up so
it'll be ready for that
what pre-pro is there to do i just
wanted to get the final script and then
pretty much we sit down and make sure
that it's good to go for production
i thought you finished the script
yesterday i mean it's done it's just
there's a couple like tweaks and uh more
than that it's just like kind of
figuring out the scope of like what kind
of
shots that will be well yeah
that's that's totally cool
[Music]
hey steve
hey steve
i love it
[Laughter]
you know i was having a bad day until i
got to hunter street but when i see
something like this i
i realize that there is a purpose in
life
that there are greater things than
foreign trade and whether or not we bomb
korea watching people do things like
this that really mean the difference in
this world only on this street i really
wish it was pitch dark now and i wish
the knives were also on fire i want this
on a wide shot these two t's right here
two titties right there
right there now we call that a tight
cowboy you've got a loose cowboy it's
where his balls are the balls are
hanging down right there get that for
when he misses you're gonna want loose
collar on another leg shot yeah that one
oh
yeah i'm excited okay
granny came to us with his idea and said
clint jones is the only person that can
play gizmo duck we are trying to figure
out the best weekend that clint can work
because he does have a job during the
weeks so we had a couple weekends booked
for him clint let us know that he's
booked a gig and is no longer available
so we have to push yet again again we
thought we had one weekend that was
about to be perfect next weekend but we
all forgot that it is nico's bachelor
party and clint is also going to be at
that so he cannot be shooting with us
so we push one more weekend and that's
the weekend so
well hopefully that works because i'm
not available the following four
weekends in a row correct so we kind of
need to make this happen
that weekend there are we're kind of
limited now so this is it so make sure
your foot's like entirely on the pad
here there you go there you go
oh that was really impressive what's the
world record for how many you can juggle
on a runway i think there's someone i
think you just said yeah i think you
just set the world record you just set a
world record yeah here well i mean let's
break it six
oh one wheel he's about to juggle seven
balls while riding the one wheel world
record breaking right no one's ever done
this
no drops
[Applause]
do we just email guinness or yeah yeah i
just it's just i got their contact we're
good can you go from here to over there
while juggling five just like
[Music]
there we go
dude that was incredible yeah first try
kind of
okay so basically i don't know friends
talk to it all but he's got this concept
for a gizmo duck video yeah because we'd
like to get it done sooner or later i
think yeah i think it'll just be a
one-day shoot up until this moment was
thinking it was a two day but i still
need to reassess like i'm gonna tell
clint one day for now okay
okay cool and if thursday doesn't work
for you clint let me know if there's a
different time that works for you okay
okay for now we'll plan on thursday take
care dude i'll talk to you soon see ya
hey how's it going can you guys walk
into the room with a camera
sometimes it means bad news i hope it's
not bad news you're the one delivering
the news oh what's the news oh
shoot on thursday
oh you can shoot there's no yay okay
cool
i need your help if you're a 3d modeler
in hard surface modeling i need help
basically modeling the bottom half of
gizmoduck if you have a real send it to
me at this email address right here uh
yes
i've never juggled guns before but i get
asked about it a lot these are real and
they're all loaded three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we would say that our action videos are
pretty cinematic because we use a lot of
good lenses
i'm not gonna juggle those i think it'd
be good don't mess up okay that's three
thousand dollars these are two thousand
dollars each ready go for it
[Music]
okay
[Music]
good job
that was really incredibly cool so the
guinness world records were live on
their facebook page so i had to do it
you know they'll give you three attempts
what exactly was the record that you
broke it was two basketball world
records it was most chess rolls uh with
three basketballs in one minute and then
longest duration juggling five
basketballs but that was a scary one the
record was 52 seconds which is a long
time so you get really tired we're gonna
break a world record we're gonna try how
about maybe we try to beat what the
record was two days ago what was the
record two days ago 52 seconds the 52
seconds was in 2014 and i just broke it
on monday whoa no way yeah so it was
like three years that record was held
and you just shattered it now you're
gonna try to break it again
uh i'm gonna at least try to break 52
seconds okay
so what are we doing here we got a stop
watch we're gonna see how long you can
go are we ready are you ready ready all
right since i make the first throw
clock is ticking
no way
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
47 so not quite the world record but it
doesn't matter i beat it on monday
[Music]
juggling josh my channel isn't just
about juggling it's right now it's all
about world records so every single
wednesday i break or set world records
it's a lot of fun and it's it's been
good
this guy breaks world records every
wednesday
what am i doing with my life